il ya deux fermiers dans le public qui
s'appelle eric et régine eric nous a
envoyé une vidéo pour faire plaisir à sa
femme pour la saint valentin
regarde ça lui sert il je me présente
donc eric le fermier marié à l'ex régime
depuis 35 ans 25 heures avec des animaux
avec peu de week-end peu de vacances
donc je compte sur toi cyril je
souhaiterais m'échapper un peux quitter
mes animaux quelques jours avec régine
surtout pour la saint valentin
donc je te remercie avec les unes qui
sont avec tous les pouvoirs et les coûts
ce public est ternie eric le fermier
nerica merci avec l'auteure diane est là
et merci régime d'être là eric et régine
il n'arrête pas de bosser
ils n'ont pas pu s'absenter de la ferme
pendant des années des années et nous
ont demandé de pouvoir partir en
vacances mais pour pouvoir partir en
vacances fallait bien qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui garde la ferme et on a
pensé à la meilleure personne ici
susceptible de garder une ferme et on a
pensé à 5 yeux de mathieu dehors
regardez bien
matthieu delormeau et dans la ferme et
en fait ils croient qu eric et régine
sont déjà partis en vacances et on aura
tous les commentaires des rivières qui
étaient cachées regard des pratiques de
l'envoi la perle rare
[Musique]
c'est ici ça c'est des remarques des
vrais qui a dirigé la campagne a
d'ailleurs fait plaisir qu'est ce que tu
penses que j'ai des mains en or qui
pousse de mission m les fouilles dans la
terre hostile
un jour
bonjour monsieur webb avait reconnu que
les fermiers
donc moi ces régimes o comme chanteuse
voilà qui t'a fait c'est la
saint-valentin agressive c'était une
surprise pour vous vous avez pas partir
en week-end vous éclater faire la nouba
nunes uniens et moi bonne nouvelle
n'occulte de la ferme
c'est vrai et oui il va faire la valise
bon au revoir mathieu
ouais ouais ouais
ou alors le top guns de la campagne
ce qu'on a bien fait de laisser les clés
de la ferme il a l'air content de lui
on va commencer par les benhaim par les
vaches nico tu sais quoi ce machin mais
vu une vache de sa vie jours
c'est la plus âgée c'est isabelle fait
la gueule cgil a pris du poids celle des
benjamins ça
makaay m'amène à jeune homme au secours
d'un jeune homme qui avait déjà perdu
jusque là surprise à eric et régine
gouverneur week-end
il voulait c'est la ferme nouveaux camps
devront maintenant le taulier c'est
waouh ça veut dire que tu prends une
fourche
montre moi parce que tu sais faire a dit
voir détails bien mac tout sur moi à la
mal ça je suis un peu l'émission on a
bien failli ces kits ont préféré jean
michel nombre de vrais voilà part que
des blacks si pour de vrai what what is
your continue nous serait ce que je te
parle qu'il faut te voilà ça ton tour
est donc bien je prenais à jouer de bien
jouer damien ça fait les bras et tout
cela c'est pour faire ça tout le long
c'est bien dans ces îles et un peu
feignant c'est regarder une arrêté
quelques brouilles parisien
pourquoi tu me regardent comme ça toi
c'est ce que tu te dis tu sens le talent
c'est toi il n'est pas à l'aise quand
même on va l évident télé beaucoup tout
ils ont tous vu les veaux qui évolue
petit à les beauty avec les petites lors
il n' ya ça joue à rien bah alors c'est
rien c'est quoi ta en plus il met son
nez je sais ce que c'est alors si tu
vois rien les filles
j'avais les découvre la vigne il a quel
âge ce gala lui trouver un petit prénom
[Musique]
bannaby la voilà on est dans le chic
dans le classe directement
c'est une de ses copines ont mis la
pagaille ce que j'allais faire dans la
journée je pense que j'étais mixité où
se trouvait un commis quelques uns de
tes pmp j'ai ramené ici m'a demandé à
ses rimes ça nous on pourra passer un
peu plus de temps sans one apprendre à
se connaître
si la france a la pression mais certes
ans que gilles verdez quand tu vois mon
nom s'afficher il répond jamais bientôt
au répondeur neuilly n'est actuellement
uniquement bon il est pas la bomba gille
c'était mathieu bon vieux morges ap un
autre maicon mais qu'est ce qui lui
arrive
mayotte qu'est ce qu'il lui arrive tu
penses de l'art en train de faire la
vache à genlis et mathieu tu as ça capte
mal tu aimes te réveiller écoute nous il
faut que tu mourras d'un gros service
chose une guerre mardi de malades c'est
horrible fait froid je suis dans une
ferme avec des vaches elle baisse
partout il ya des veaux des trucs chez
des tounes a pu soit qu'une toujours été
là pour toi je t'ai arranger des plans
pour des mains fait tout ah bah c'est
autre chose que les menaces de google je
parle a quand même
[Musique]
sur toi s'allume voilà il commençait
avec furieux à je sais qui se fait
appeler bbc tomates
tu sais que je t'aime suspectant j'ai un
bon plan le futur croquer la petite
copine
ils essaient de la tyrie cela je te dis
je suis dans un spa 5 étoiles jacuzzi
hammam gommage au sel de guérande ckoi
grand ou le programme prend un maillot
de bain et prends tes rêves pas à viser
les visions à la cruche tenez vous avez
une et votre
vous avez vous avez peut-être compris
qu'ils allaient rejoindre matthieu dans
cette aventure puisqu'elle va le
rejoindre dans un instant et vous alors
déjà une date déjà de du début là bas
mais à thieu il faut qu'il revienne un
quart un sage un stage plus long
d'accord sinon avant de le rencontrer
oui sympa ça va mais là la ferme les
animaux de la ferme c'est pas son truc
donc il va commencer en cp disons s'il
vient et on voit synthé tranquillement
et puis il ya l'autre élève qui vous a
rejoint à regarder elle croyait qu'elle
venait dans un spa est elle allée à la
ferme rejoint de mathieu c'est parti
à aider
oui je crois je suis perdue le gps il a
amené devant une ferme
il ya des chevaux est tous là à ma
droite ouais non je te vois c'est pas
des chevaux et des ânes mais c'est pas
grave mais moyennement attend j'arrête
ouais tu vas rire ça va non en fait tu
vas en fait c'est des amis à moi j'ai
invité surprise pour la saint valentin
ils sont partis trois jours en italie et
moi femme
eh ben je leur ai dit je m'occupe de ta
ferme et orthez gentil tu vois un bleu
de travail
tu vas te priver de torcher les vaches
et puis qatar à sourire merde mais je
patron ed sont renvoyées par un patronat
excuse moi tu as va rappeler en pensant
que tu étais une amie des grands avec
ses potes seule chine
reste là
les hanches vaches au [ __ ] je pensais
qu'à deux ils allaient faire une équipe
et c'est vraiment un type de bras cassés
[Applaudissements]
jamais un cochon de l'ordre et [ __ ] ça
nous a bike qui ce qui est plus
intelligent l'a bien
c'est bien
mais j'aime pas ça bien là j'ai mal je
vais vous qu'une remontée à ne rien
[ __ ] mon appartement je vise m'a fait
ça n'empêche cyril hanouna je sais pas
comment il fait pour gérer tout sans
l'équipe est là la femme du cochon c'est
une [ __ ] lucas la salle du conseil
la conne d'amiens pour bloquer le canal
de suez et si ça se fait beaucoup
salazie cet honneur en plus sains comme
le fer à cheval
il en faudra plus que ça
[Musique]
il raconte n'importe quoi elle le croit
mais la vie est ce qu'on va les faire
maintenant donc on va aller traire les
années on espère gentil en train de
l'endormir sa mamelle c'est un mal
choisi mais papa de la veille
cet art est saisie avec le tube est bien
plus bon on a bien bossé tous les deux
très heureux d'être occupés pour
terminer cours de tracteurs ouais lance
indices pas fait couler un bain à
l'autre il prend soin de loterie mais
des huiles de dans cette affaire ni la
haine du tout
tu 133 autres acteurs
mais c'est pas possible mais général ils
vont faire des grosses bêtises mais
qu'elle est nulle
c'est pas ce bassin au foot et la bombe
a fait confiance on vous donne les clés
regardez celle chantiers partout nommé
rosen virait vous êtes viré les labours
et on a tous vu les cochons ils sont en
liberté
les cas précis
la capitaine mais moi je crois que je
tente un inconscient soit des
détracteurs c'est capucine parce que moi
je voulais pas ça va s'avérer en fait un
projet risque à samedi
ces animaux et on vous trouve en train
de faire mes courses tracteur l'après
midi ou ce dommage veux plus me voir
tu étais retourné à paris sur un plateau
je crois que c'est là que vous êtes bien
mais tu es content de toi tu as fait
n'importe quoi
voilà on rentre un peu chaud maintenant
c'est vers des six sélections devrait
tirer comme ça n'a jamais été viré de ma
vie sauvée une première fois est
évidemment ça se passe avec toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui joue la mère que je
voulais dire les cherry et puis rien
grâce à mathieu 4-6 vous avez été en
voyage
régine vous avez fait un beau voyage oui
nous sommes allés à rome voilà un rebond
à l'image regardez vous avez passé
combien de jours à rome eh bien deux
jours et une nuit et de jour et nuit à
rome et les shihri c'est pas fini parce
que j'aimerais vous envoyer pour un
voyage plus long voilà parce que là
c'est fake deux jours et j'aimerais vous
offrir un autre voyage la plus longtemps
d'une semaine et je laisserais mathieu
et capucine à la ferme pendant une
semaine mais là vraiment sans vous ça
veut dire quoi on est parti avec la beac
est formidable je voudrais vous
remercier et vraiment fait un travail
formidable vraiment vous êtes drôles et
on embrasse tous les agriculteurs qui
n'est vraiment
avec star
nos animaux c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de partir de s'absenter pour
des personnes qui ont un chien ou un
chat
voyez déjà le business que c'est pour
partager leurs goûts et vous vous avez
vu ici rit je voudrais surtout remercier
parce que régine depuis plusieurs années
elle me demandait d'aller à rome pour
visiter le vatican est chose faite et
c'est vrai que c'est un compétiteur tu
peux peindre nouveau régime l'air
circule
merci beaucoup et vous êtes formidables
et bravo que tous nous fait un diplôme à
donner à mathieu de mathieu il avait un
diplôme quand même ouais c'est agir un
certificat de baptême alors allez-y
donnez lui donnez lui alléger à désirer
une deuxième batterie
[Applaudissements]
voilà à tuer les très content au brésil
mais sait on a une petite image encore
je crois mon jean luc ah oui parce que
ils n'ont pas pu tout mettre dans le
sujet donc j'ai récupéré quelques rushs
et voilà et malheureusement ils soient
pas ambiance et et mathieu et capitaux
et essayer d'apprendre le métier de
fermier à des enfants vous conseille
d'en confier pas alors vos enfants n'ont
plus regardé sa monnaie alors il paraît
qu'on est venu poser des questions à des
experts de la ferme est bien celui-là
nous sommes là qui commence comme on
faisait un fait pour que leur chef à 100
d'eads et moi si je me dois bonne
question ça pose avant tant
d'intelligence des ta curiosité capuche
alors à votre avis comment là va tuer
des bébés c'est pas moi la valeur est la
cause elle accouche d'un vous voilà oui
mais l'antibois tard par antoine tu peux
te tutoyer à une question comment les
vaches islam alors je crois qui se
lèchent non d'abord c'est un animal on
sait pas beaucoup mais qui est pas très
propre ouais tu vois sur des années un
peu comme gilles verdez c'est ça peut
rester d'aider des semaines sans style
et du tout pour ça qu'elle dégage une
odeur très forte absolument que vous
n'avez pas l'autre côté du poste mais
qu'on a nous est très près dé relancer
pour cent mais juste à côté isabelle
toujours car elle n'a plus de mandat
elle est plutôt doha du tout voilà la
vie des animaux
nos amis bien merci merci merci d'avoir
été avec nous on vous aime fort merci
vous voulez dire donc que tu as bien
regarder mathieu à telle par un donc je
souhaiterais que chaque année de
naissance de mabi la venue voir voilà il
l'a quand même d'attiser et basse très
bien et doit merci merci merci et bravo
mathieu bravo valérie je vous ai senti
un petit peu nerveux après mathieu a
promis changement pourquoi il dit que
gilles pu week isabelle elle à doha
ouais tu m'as dit que j'étais une vache
capucine qui les a traité d'abruti c'est
pas tes pas très gentiment de 40 ans
alors vraiment je te prie de m'excuser
pour vhc sam est sorti comme ça j'ai
justement lorsque je te reproche c'est
parce que je passais pas c'est parce que
tu sais que c'est faux et je sais que tu
as beaucoup d'humour
c'est à grande qualité on veut te dire
pour savoir robert
[Applaudissements]